let's talk about this honestly it really
depends on the size of your data for
small amounts of binary data very very
small amounts of binary data you could
actually put the raw data in the
database there are blob types and those
are supported and work pretty well
however as you start putting larger data
into the database
it gets pretty inefficient and you end
up writing a lot more code well as far
as storing the files in a public folder
on the device is concerned well that
might work if you actually wanted to
share those files but typically you
don't want to share those files with
other applications so storing them in a
public folder on the device isn't a very
good idea but the third option is pretty
good storing the files in a private
folder and then referencing the location
in the database now admittedly you might
not even need to put them into the
database at all but it's often nice to
do this if you need to do any kind of
queries on them you can store metadata
in your database and store files in a
private folder this is what Android does
in the gallery